hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fleeing the complex now
this is a direct sequel to escaping the
airship which came after stealing the
diamond which came after escaping the
prison which came after something about
a bank I don't know I played them all
out of order so I don't really know
which ones come after which but I know
that I love these games and I've been
waiting for this one for a long time
[Music]
hello who are you
do not what does the sign say do not
either way I'm very bad at these games
which means I'm very good at finding all
the failures in this game has over 60
unique failures that I've seen or that
I've heard about mmm
why should was that you're flirting
noise and how did she do that she's very
strong okay bye I won't come rescue you
I suppose oh maybe I should help her out
maybe oh hi oh yay I got a friend oh man
there's gonna be so many different ways
look at how much thank you
I ended the buffing up my guys in doing
like 70 damage that's funny
I'm gonna go with the one with the fart
sound effect because
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I don't know what happened why did
they all start dancing oh man I love
these games so much
tall guy I want to go with tall guy
excuse me okay all right then oh we did
good man all the animation that went
into these games is amazing okay how do
I do that
oh the gravitate er this didn't work
very good the last time and I don't know
how we're gonna have the force but oh
the gravity
no judo throw okay the force do we have
that oh god why okay all right then
thank you thanks ma'am booster grenade
and taser okay you're not even gonna
logic yourself out of this crossbow
grenade oh man I love this game
I like I remember when I was playing
escaping the airship and it gave me the
best belly laughs anyway enough about me
more about the game
shut up markiplier no one cares what you
think taser sniper Oh
so thank you toss well I don't know why
but toss there is convict yet why does
that work why did that one work
Oh God what I've done hello hi sorry
[Applause]
wait really
adrenalin make a face I'm gonna go with
adrenaline oh hi oh hi well okay
huh if I was going that fast anyway why
would you work before what do you think
that will upset
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we were saved by random chance man
there are a lot of ways to go about
things okay how about the truck not as
cool as the motorcycle but it's pretty
good anyway let me guess this is a
company owned truck and it's gonna go
right back into the building okay
alright then alright the really cool
motorcycle that's probably the best way
to go holy crap where'd you get that why
is he still alive
[Applause]
yeah I got a friend and we went out
together yeah I really don't know how
long this game is gonna be because that
that was one of the endings and it had
so many other places that I could have
gone so what they've added which is
really nice about this is they've added
this which is a map of the different
things that I could do and all the
failures that I've seen so I can
actually go back and play through and
try to find the failures again so that's
exactly what I'm gonna do from here okay
I love this okay the gravit or which I
knew was gonna be bad cuz it's always
been bad Oh
sniper crossbow Oh
oh my god see that in an instant replay
[Laughter]
oh man YouTube poops and MLG
compilations are my favorite things to
watch on YouTube okay anyway alright
pass by oh okay alright blend in oh well
then that was less interesting as I
thought it'd be the knee prepareathon
groin who the hell is that back there
alright I'm gonna go the branching path
here oh no why would I abandon my friend
it'd be such a douchey thing to do
alright let's do exactly that thing
Ellie will remember that about to bad
Ellie I gotta do this all myself look at
how much thank you how about a
pickpocket something guys I'm doing like
70 damage cool a Skyrim reference oh
yeah that's command melody huh
ah Wind Waker references I love it
oh okay well good for me then sprint on
yeah my guys are doing was that the
convict yeah a fixer what are we
supposed to do when someone tries to
escape again I'll think shoot him
oh yes that sounds right okay what the
kitchen because why not are you serious
w you wha don't you accuse me come on
just admit it wasn't me
oh man I gotta stop picking the silly
ones because it's obviously the silic
ones aren't gonna be the one that
actually works and played these games
enough I should probably know about this
here's the gravit or Oh Howard you all
right hey why did hello what why do that
one work why do I always pick the ones
that work let's do the logical long shot
bang I wonder how this is gonna go wrong
Oh
[Music]
whoa-ho that didn't make any sense
okay let's try a spring that almost
looked like it oh okay
the button sure this is working god
dammit lunch is on me
oh hi oh okay even though there's a riot
going who there's not a riot going on
yet never mind all right
which bungee yes fine explode balloon
because logic is reason but no it's it's
oxygen it's it's not lighter than air
it's not it's just air in that it
wouldn't oh it got so it was so big it's
less wiggle friction I'm not smart
yeah balance seems logical well plunger
boots he helium I forget that this game
kind of forgets about reality a little
bit it worked
I'm so happy all right let's just keep
moving forward
ah the Box get a nice little Solid Snake
rivers no one's this beautiful thing
what just a box okay
leaf Mario
no one would notice that flying over
their shipyard okay
oh yes hopefully I can blow up the
entire world one more time Oh this
Kerbal space program all over again
bingi not a big ship on the big one oh
[Laughter]
okay oh damn it alrighty then fine I'll
take the little dinghy but I'm not happy
about it
goodbye everybody someone just leave
thank you Miss Smith then I guess it's
totally fine
[Music]
plunger boots how can this go wrong oh
no oh no logic takes place now shad
shadows I don't know what a shad dozer
is the unseen stick is the deadliest
blend in become a shadow like a shadow
in the night I'm gonna be honest with
you this one isn't that great okay fix
ready oh oh oh oh that's horrifying
okay so we did that so one of these is
the failures I want to wait for a
transfer all right let's go wait what oh
no wait a minute this looks like a lot
like the other game yes
[Music]
this never works oh god where am I
wasn't even close to what Starcraft litt
sounded like oh my god ok sonic pulse
it's so horrible sometimes it's gonna
cut me don't cut me oh hey good well
that guy died but I guess it's pretty ok
top hat yes drill pod sounds awesome it
worked last time
yeah you can't science your way through
this one you full lies oh come on hey
that's going huh
ok sure yes good I don't know I don't
know what the capital among goal is I
read what you were saying I don't know
don't skip my words ok dogs have feet
paws really press the Sun in the sneaky
ending press the Sun in the sneaky
ending Oh which one is correct this yay
confession both correct press the right
mouse button yes Oh
don't press this button okay oh you dick
ah god damn it undercover agent sure
thanks buddy neurotoxin always good
probably gonna kill me
can't wait oh I didn't know that it
started on the apocalypse okay that was
that sunny pulsed laser plane fake
illness let's go cookie where did I get
a cookie is that the big inator cookie
oh oh oh it's so horrible so then there
was a branching path over here
government why would I call the
government hi government oh Henry how's
it going mm actually
Wow yeah I've heard of that place
actually I'm pretty close yeah I'm on a
mission but I should have some time to
swing by and just try to get outside and
all oh I don't even get a choice here oh
they spotted me I'm an earth Bend
oh but that was amazing there's so many
cool things going on oh I was doing so
good
all right flash where you going like
this Oh what hey so I I see the wall oh
yeah nice puffball you weren't even
trying with that one
okay you got this yeah yeah all right
[Laughter]
ah snipe him get him you got it I trust
you oh god no of course okay mini copter
this doesn't make a lot of sense but hey
nothing in this game ever does Oh
ah screw you buddy I'm just I'm gonna
I'm gonna give up apparently oh okay
all right then I'm gonna gun it oh I'm
very dead we're both dead now good job
I'll go for the gun man Oh hmm okay
obvious choices obvious oh hey this is
so fun no okay whitter kooky cool okay I
almost got all of them okay but I'm not
going to call you up see without you I
become the leader of the topit clan
again I just wanted to look you in the
eyes as I took it all back goodbye sad I
mean you've died in horrible ways but
those weren't official endings I guess
it just fails I wonder if that's gonna
be the continuation for the next game ah
such a good game he puts the developer
put so much time into this and it's
totally free which is awesome support
the developer man alright only one way
unless to go play dead he's getting
gooey yeah you know new one Henry he's
dead yes put him with others okay oh
okay alright then well charge tackle huh
oh that worked by lady oh no yes yes oh
yes you do oh god I had a funny feeling
you can't go too fast you gotta go fast
not too fast I wonder what happens if
the timer ends up I probably just get
shot how many people want to bet I just
get shot oh god I just got shot okay
oh wow cool nice defensive line I don't
know Wow
wait why is he speaking German I thought
these were guys with Russian lot to gun
oh wait a minute
we went Garry's Mod what if I could
[Laughter]
throw okay all right then thank you Oh
[Applause]
looks like Henry stick man stick stick
men yeah Henry stickmin has
No ooh this like that game that I like
oh it's game called oh let's get game
it's Game Boy Advance game
oh it's with tanks and war oh that's
what it looks like oh man you guys know
what I'm talking about right Advance
Wars that's what it is oh so cool
I love that game fun oh god no oh well
that went well thank you tank definitely
gonna be a good encounter it's so
advanced wars yeah I figured that I
would go mmm nice pun there guy with
sward ha that's like Final Fantasy
Tactics Wow where did you get the sward
buddy and you do some way we cannot let
him get through this gate oh nice ass
costume why you stampd all oh no truck
go go buddy
you got it I believe in you
oh I'm not done yet I thought that was
an escape
bring it on oh hey oh oh no it was so
sudden who is so sudden at that time all
right whatever
[Laughter]
Wow run Henry run run for your life I
have to sanity I am you're the first
person to escape the wall this is the
end for you options here nice I wouldn't
have thought that would have been it
oh wow I'm just too good at this game
that was those papers please reverence
nice nice
okay wow I missed quite a bit why don't
I go I'm gonna want to do this all again
no even though there's no way oh I don't
know what this is gonna do but okay no
here you dig oh hi Freddy how's it going
you just gonna keep doing that the end
is so sudden for poor Henry whoa jerk
I didn't have time to listen to whatever
the hell you were talking Oh God no okay
surrender hey I'm gonna go back into
jail and then be there forever it's
gonna be great oh it's so sad option
three okay well then I did something I
think I got all the unique ones didn't I
yeah I think I did but but I've gotten
all the endings and I've gotten all of
the fails but I know there's gonna be
secrets in this game I know there's
gotta be secrets I know there have to be
okay so the medals that I don't have are
two secret medals
I got XX newb Slayer spooked I need
Waldo nailed it
No rise and shine 101 filmation's and
then master the wall and then patron of
tunes so I'm gonna get to these as soon
as I got a walk through here or not
really a guide there are five different
scenes in the game in which a man with a
briefcase can be seen out of place okay
leave okay so there's a man with a
briefcase somewhere here oh there is Oh
got him
okay so there's so much like half life -
that's awesome
okay so I just need to find all the
places where he is kick toss okay this
should be the next one there should be
one here yes I did it I got him okay so
that's two okay so he should appear
again in the earth bending scene okay
that's three okay so I just need four so
I'm almost got it
Oh got it oh this is Karloff okay oh I
should have known this is the only guy
that actually got brutally horribly
murdered where are you where right there
you are I got it I think I got it I
think I got it okay so there's this one
more and that's a topic oh sure there is
oh come on it was so quick
yes Oh God all right that's a metal that
took well that was actually hard to get
so the next one I'm gonna do is nailed
it and I know this one had the power
jump I guess yeah there we go okay so if
I clicked sooner I wouldn't flop and
fail on those jumps plunger boots babbit
Ababa vu
oink okay there's another metal we had
here called AEIOU hey-oh
that doesn't look good something tells
me that's awfully sinister okay so I
only need Waldo and Waldo is here right
there oh that was an easy one okay so
the only ones left is patron of tunes so
if I go to the credits see the credits
of specific endings ah so I see
ha ha I got it ok cool
I got another medal I'm rolling in
medals okay so I just need bruh no I
don't know where bruh
no is but then I need 101 fails
okay easy enough can do where the hell
is Bruno - by clicking on the moon in
different scenes in one by clicking on
the item box what's the item box be more
descriptive you douche okay okay okay
okay I know I know I know oh that's
right yeah I got it I got it okay
alright okay alright okay okay alright
[Applause]
[Music]
finally ah now I just got to get 101
fails and then I have all the medals I
literally have all the medals thank you
walk through but you're not very
descriptive I still had to like go
through all the different fails trying
to find cuz it was so vague it said on
the moon in two different scenes I
didn't know what scenes it was and then
it was just like on the item box I'm
like who's the item box okay excuse me
pardon me I'm just trying to fail don't
mind me
oh hey I did it
101 filmation's I wanted to end on the
dancing one I'll do the dancing one
anyway so cuz I loved it so that should
be everything I've got rise and shine
Bruno nailed it Waldo's newb Slayer
AEIOU spooked easy metal hunter one
formation golden boy pedro tunes credit
TBG i PDK CA iro
and then i thought that was gonna be
like a secret no I thought there was
gonna be a little Easter egg or
something
Oh putting all that work you're not
gonna put in a little bit little
itty-bitty X okay anyway okay so that
was fleeing the complex I did everything
that I possibly could in every way that
I could possibly do it I got every
single medal and I need a little
assistance from the walk through but
that's okay but thank you everybody so
much for watching I love these games
these flash games harken back to the era
of Newgrounds where I used to like play
these games that people poured their
heart and soul into totally for free and
they would just put them up on the
internet for people to enjoy that is a
wonderful wonderful era of gaming and
this kind of holds true to that so thank
you puffballs United for making the game
and if you guys haven't played it
already or haven't played the other ones
you can check out my videos of them in
the description there's a whole playlist
all out of order and please let me know
what you think of this game do you enjoy
this game do you like this game I love
these games they've got so much charm
they've got so much fun
so much work put into the animation so
much humor in them it's super super cool
to see that these games and these types
games are still alive and well so thank
you everybody for watching thank you
puffballs for making it and as always I
will see you
oh I forgot I'm not captain falcon